bon
chère madame la chancelière
chers collègues
nous sommes heureux de vous accueillir
au kremlin
nous avons dû nous rencontrer si je me
suis bien je l'année dernière
lors de la conférence sur la libye qui
avait été organisée à berlin à votre
initiative
d'ailleurs c'est grâce ce travail que
nous avons réussi à bien avancer sur ce
dossier
mais nous allons parler encore
et là je tiens à noter que l'allemagne
demeure un de nos partenaires majeurs
prioritaire en europe et dans le monde
et notamment grâce à vos efforts en tant
que chancelière pendant ces 16 années
après la chine
et malgré le fait que nous avons une
baisse du volume des échanges en 2020
mais maintenant nous avons encore une
très forte augmentation pour le premier
semestre de l'année
nous avons tous les mécanismes de
travail et qui fonctionnent les groupes
de travail
il est actuellement l'année de
l'allemagne en russie
et cette année est consacrée au
développement économique au
développement général
et nous sommes toujours en contact
téléphonique
et il y a beaucoup de questions que nous
devons traiter en personne
et donc je suis convaincu que ce n'est
pas seulement
une dernière visite d'adieu de votre
part en tant que chancelière mais c'est
aussi une visite de travail au contenu
qui est riche
bienvenus
merci monsieur le président chers
vladimir
oui c'est ma visite est d'être vu et je
suis heureuse mais il a été bien dit que
c'est également une visite de travail
nous avons beaucoup de choses dont il
faudrait discuter je ne peux pas ne pas
évoquer le fait qu'il y à 80 ans
l'allemagne nazie attaque et l'union
soviétique
et
justement pendant cet anniversaire je
viens de déposer une gerbe à la tombe
d'un soldat inconnu même si nous avons
des différends dans nos opinions je
pense que c'est une très bonne chose que
nous puissions discuter et nous allons
garder le contact et continuer à
discuter dans l'avenir
comme j'ai déjà dit nous avons des
choses dont il faudrait discuter à
commencer par les relations bilatérales
ensuite il s'agit des questions sur la
scène internationale de l'agenda
international
la libye par exemple la conférence qui a
lieu à l'afghanistan relations
commerciales bilatérales
entre la russie
l'allemagne l'année de l'allemagne en
russie qui a lieu maintenant il faudra
aussi discuté des questions de la
société civile des organisations
commerciales et nous avons
des choses à faire pendant notre réunion
et je vous remercie d'avoir cette
opportunité